18 présences positive confirmée
installer les amis je vous présente
sébastien 2e escadron tenez vos
positions sébastien ferme les yeux a bat
elle fait le tout de suite colonel en a
un problème
vous n'avez pas idée à quel point
c'est une abomination elle doit être
définitivement rayé de la surface de la
terre
les vampires avec des mitraillettes rien
acheter la nuit il appartiendra
c'était là quand on emménage et c'est
quelque chose qu'on avance de dieu
pourquoi moi ce que je vois merci
beaucoup
ils massacrent chacun d'entre eux
jusqu'au territoire tuer tout le monde
recule tout de suite au nom du père les
fils et du saint-esprit où je vous en
conjure auquel tous je veux conduire
durée
c'était le point critique gastronomique
de nos jours
[Musique]